the movie opens up with a guy named
Callum Aldrich who is in the middle of
his cleaning shift at an office during
this he receives a call from an unknown
person who blackmails him into coming to
a specified location within 15 minutes
or else he'll Le callum's private
screenshots to his friends and family
and callum's been screenshot in naked
dogs feeling helpless Callum rushes to
the set location only to stumble upon a
crash site where the driver is lying on
the ground while the passenger appears
helpless inside the vehicle overwhelmed
with Panic Callum calls 911 to report
the situation moments later the driver
who is pretending to be dead suddenly
wakes up and incapacitates Callum from
behind before abducting him this sounds
like a job for the sexiest man alive the
following morning the police arrive at
the scene with Chief Inspector John
Luther leading the case Luther's
colleague Martin briefs him that the
passenger in the car is Siri Jones who
disappeared 7 years ago after
scrutinizing the crime scene details
Luther deduces that Callum wasn't just
caught in the wrong place at the wrong
time but someone had intended to abduct
him he then reaches out to callum's
Mother Karin and Promises to find her
son Luther has seen at least a hundred
people die he probably shouldn't have
promised that amidst the bystanders
there's a man named David Roby seemingly
concerned by Luther's involvement in the
case he is revealed to be the culprit
behind the abductions knowing that
Luther will be a huge obstacle in his
plan David and his absurd haircut dig up
dirt on the various illegal acts Luther
has committed as a police officer aiming
to wipe him off the case a few days
later Luther is dragged into court
facing a multitude of charges including
intimidation of suspects evidence of
tampering and bribery as a consequence
of these unlawful Deeds he is imprisoned
in hawksmore Maximum Security Prison
this news excites David as he can now
proceed with his plans without any
interference and it was so much easier
than it should have been David turns out
to be a wealthy Traer and serial killer
who blackmails people for their dark
secrets in the prison the inmates hate
Luther as several of them are
incarcerated because of him hence they
often form alliances and beat him up the
movie then cuts to a few years later one
day Karin receives a call in which she
hears her son crying she tries to talk
to him but before that she has provided
a location to meet him without thinking
twice Karin drives to the location which
is an empty house upon entering she
calls out for her son and soon comes
across a horrifying scene lifeless
bodies suspended from the ceiling
including [__] soon parents of other
victims also arrive and it appears that
everything has been planned just then
the room is set on fire during which
Karin spots a masked man staring at her
from the window she then runs away in
the nick of time but unfortunately the
other parents are not so lucky the next
day police arrive at the scene and DCI
odet rain is now leading the case after
a swift examination of the house rain
holds a meeting with her team and
outlines that the earliest murder dates
back 11 years with the most recent being
from the previous year she speculates
that the Acts were carefully planned and
carried out over an extended period of
time so there will be a lot of data to
parse she then assigns the team to find
out a commonality between all the
murders which will take them closer to
the killer meanwhile within the confines
of the prison Luther receives an
envelope that is written 65.8 on it he
understands it to be a radio frequency
because what the hell else would it be
and upon tuning in here's a recording of
callum's anguished voice recorded just
before his death the recording also
features the voice of David who admits
that he is the one to put him in jail
and challenges Luther to stop him if he
can afterwards Karin visits Luther in
jail and berates him for not finding her
son's killer Luther tries to talk to her
but she isn't ready to listen after a
brief conversation Karin leaves and as
she gets into a car we learn that David
is the one who brought her there he is
pretending to console her in every way
he can how'd they become friends I don't
know who cares later on Luther uses his
hidden cell phone to inform rain of the
broadcast but she refuses to accept any
help from a criminal criminal in
addition she directs her subordinate
Archie to get Luther's phone confiscated
left with no other options Luther
contacts his former colleague Dennis to
help him break out of the prison but
before they can delve further into the
plan the prison officers confiscate his
phone later Luther also leazes with the
prison guards to get himself transferred
to another prison with lower level
security the guards refuse saying that
they can't change the system hearing
this Luther devises a plan to have the
inmates attack him which will ultimately
result in the system relocating him not
sure how that works or why he waited 2
years to do it but let's just watch him
punch some large men that same night one
of the prisoners attempts to commit the
unthinkable attracting the attention of
the control room officers they somehow
managed to save the prisoner but out of
the blue he knocks them out and escapes
with the key was the guy Faking It are
the police officers in on it what the
hell is going on the prisoner then
unlocks all the cells initiating chaos
following this many inmates gang up on
Luther and dish out a brutal punishment
on him when the guards see this they
eventually decide to transfer him just
as he planned later Luther is being
driven to another prison when a black
van intervenes it's Dennis and his men
who incapacitate the officers and rescue
Luther from captivity they then drop him
off at a garage and Luther pays them for
their work now that he's freed from
confinement Luther vows to capture the
serial killer on the other hand rain
learns about Luther's Escape so she
summons the retired officer Martin for
help since no one knows Luther better
than him Martin agrees to help and goes
to the prison to check Luther's
belongings he finds the radio frequency
and deduces that Luther's location can
be traced by tracking the frequency back
to its source meanwhile Luther arrives
at the site of the broadcast and meets a
tattoo artist named Derek he demands to
know who used his radio frequency but
Derek and his absurd haircut are
initially hesitant to divulge any
information however after a little
intimidation Derrik confesses that he
was blackmailed by a man for some of his
private videos according to Derek he
received the transmitter through a
courier and was instructed to leave it
running for 24 hours before ditching it
somewhere Derek also provides Luther
with a cell phone through which the
blackmailer contacts him with this
information Luther grabs the cell phone
and leaves just before the police arrive
elsewhere we see a group of David's
workers who are keeping an eye on people
from all over the world they have
seemingly hacked into phones cameras
tablets and home security cameras
enabling them to spy on people in this
way David retrieves their confidential
activities which he gets a bunch of
secretaries to punch into Excel
spreadsheets and then he exploits for
blackmail compelling them to carry out
his bidding in the next scene Luther
contacts Martin seeking help in tracing
a phone number the latter reluctantly
agrees and informs him of the location
of Picadilly circus after this Martin
also relays the information to rain who
then deploys armed police sc19 to
apprehend Luther and the serial killer
upon arriving at the location Luther
dials the number from Derrick's cell
phone and David who happens to be there
receives it this allows Luther to spot
him trapped and left with no options
David immediately grabs a kid from the
crowd and holds him at knife point with
a Sinister smile he declares that this
is just the beginning precious actually
it's about the halfway point smeagle the
next second several of his blackmailed
victims begin jumping off from nearby
building one after another creating
chaos David seizes this as the perfect
opportunity and runs towards the subway
Luther pursues him but he is also chased
by the police officers at one point
Luther catches up to David which results
in a physical altercation between them
our hero eventually gains the upper hand
pinning David down but the fight is soon
interrupted by a police officer Luther
urges him to Cuff David first but the
officer strikes him to the ground this
enables David to stab the officer and
flee Luther then applies first aid to
the officer's wound before making his
own Escape in the aftermath David calls
his Inside Man Archie questioning why he
didn't inform him about Luther's escape
from prison when the ladder fails to
give a response David threatens to leak
his confidential videos he then calls
one of his men named kachima and asks
about their pl's progress in response
kachima shows him video footage of a
group of teenagers whom he has captured
on the other hand Luther contacts Martin
and asks him to activate speaker phone
mode he then shares his insights about
the commonality they've been seeking
according to Luther David is
blackmailing people by recording their
private videos and killing them he also
asserts that nowadays the fear of Shame
and being caught is way more powerful
than the fear of death that's right
Luther just guessed all that [__] amidst
this conversation rain traces Luther's
location and dispatches a group of
officers to apprehend him however Luther
senses this so he destroys his phone and
Lees the area that same night rain calls
her daughter Ana to tell her to sleep on
time because she won't be home due to
her busy work since the girl is alone it
becomes easy for David to break into the
house and kidnap her at the same time
Luther visits Karin to gather additional
insights about the killer he believes
that the murderer knew some secret about
Callum which is why he went to see him
assuming that Karin might have knowledge
of the killer Luther inquires if anyone
knew has come into her life since
callum's death in response she tells him
about a certain Tommy whom she met at a
support group here it is revealed that
Tommy is none other than David at the
police headquarters Martin highlights a
pattern wherein at least five families
have been approached by a man in his 40s
over recent years the names vary but the
descriptions share a common likeness on
checking their database rain finds out
David's name but before she can provide
this information to her team David
contacts her telling her about Anya he
then proposes a deal he'll release the
little girl if she brings Luther to him
following this rain reaches out to
Luther arranging a meeting at a
restaurant as they meet she cleverly
subdues him and prepares to take him
away but Luther isn't going to give up
so easily she tries to put him in the
trunk but he's just simply too big he
convinces her to work together by
mentioning that there are several kids
like Anya locked up right now and if
they don't act they will be killed after
this the two dig up information on David
and find about his ex-wife Georgette
apparently she cheated on him with some
other guy and as a punishment he burnt
her face now she is confined to a
wheelchair unable to move properly she
also looks really scary rain and Luther
visit Georgette at her house and request
for her help in Catching David At first
she hesitates fearing the consequences
of revealing information however upon
learning about the predicament of rain's
daughter she reveals that David owns
property abroad in Norway with this
newfound lead Luther and Rain decide to
travel to Norway in order to rescue the
captives before leaving though Luther
calls Martin seeking one last favor
later on Archie learns about rain's
departure and relays the information to
David hearing this David understands
georgette's betrayal and blackmails
Archie to execute her with no other
choice Archie sneaks into georgette's
place but just before injecting her with
a lethal drug he is intercepted by
Martin and other police officers it's
the same favor Luther asked earlier as
he knew that David would try to harm her
Archie who isn't ready to turn himself
in administers the drug to his own ass
in the next scene Lutheran rain finally
arrive at David's mansion in Norway
which is covered in snow upon entering
they come across a series of mannequins
and a girl suspended from the ceiling
believing that it's Ana rain breaks down
in tears and directs her anger towards
Luther she says it should be you up
there which is absurd because it's her
fault that the bad guy got away earlier
she also shouts at him to leave her
alone complying Luther exits the room
and makes his way out to a secret
underground bunker not long after rain
realizes that the suspended body doesn't
belong to Ana borderline unbelievable
that she didn't notice this immediately
but before she can return to Luther she
ambushed by kachima got a kachima back
in the basement David attacks Luther and
restrains him with a chain after a while
he starts a live stream titled the red
bunker where he subjects kidnapped
victims to fatal torment this live
stream is watched by his followers who
derive enjoyment from the gruesome
scenes and vote on what will happen to
the victims David announces that he has
a surprise opening act for his followers
and it's not just his dumbass turtleneck
he introduces Luther as a special guest
shortly after rain is also brought into
the bunker where Ana is held hostage
David then tries to force the detectives
to hurt each other however at one point
Luther addresses the live audience
revealing that the police are tracking
them all with their IP addresses and are
on the way here this prompts the
followers to exit the live stream at a
fear enraging David as a result he
leaves the room and locks the door using
his phone reacting quickly Luther takes
down a guard frees rain and makes his
way out of the room just before the door
seals shut this leaves rain Ana and
kachima trapped inside soon after the
kerosene spray activates foreshadowing
an imminent fire rain implores kimoff to
unlock the door but the ladder instead
launches an attack on her a fierce
fighten sees between them but despite
being physically outmatched rain somehow
manages to incapacitate her opponents
somehow indeed that punch looked soft
meanwhile David attempts to flee in his
Jeep but Luther manages to board the
vehicle too an intense fight ensues
between the two while the Jeep off-roads
like a badass hell out by a Jeep but but
It ultimately crashes into a frozen lake
David tries to swim out but he's trapped
inside the ice and dies Luther succeeds
in unlocking the bunker door using
David's phone thereby rescuing Raina and
Ana but by this time Luther's own breath
starts to wne he is about to pass out
but the police divers show up in the
nick of time that's right in the 3
minutes since the Jeep hit the water
they showed up and put on full scuba
gear and they get Luther out in the
aftermath of these events Luther is
rushed to the hospital back in London
the news of the serial Killer's death is
also on television which brings a sense
of contentment to Karin in the final
scene Luther is approached by a senior
official who offers him a job at the
police departments do I get to
be7 no subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching